so I hope I don't lose because if I do
lose it it the meaning of a transcends
far beyond violin playing on a boardwalk
Ocean City Maryland has long been known
for its bustling boardwalk packed with
the sights smells and sounds of summer
and through outdoor amplification we had
numerous businesses that were that were
getting louder and louder the city hall
however felt the noise was becoming too
much to bear and approved an ordinance
prohibiting anyone from being audible
for more than 30 feet on the boardwalk
it wasn't to penalize but it was to try
to ensure that everybody had an
opportunity to enjoy Ocean City
reasonably while they were visiting if I
had to come out here and played that I
was told I would I would be cited and
then I would have I would be subject to
jail time William Jose had been street
performing on the public boardwalk until
he was stopped by police that I played
here for 18 years and and there was
never any problem with my noise tell
that this ordinance was passed and all
of a sudden I'm a problem all sorts of
sounds are audible at 30 feet as they
reached out to his local ACLU to defend
his right to play music the ordinance
was written so broadly that it also
picked up people that were performing on
the street and it didn't it it didn't
make as much sense when applied to those
individuals a distance limitation that
notion City chose was so restrictive and
when we presented our case to the judge
we said outright we do not object to the
concept of having a noise ordinance and
in fact we agree that ocean city's
within its rights to create a noise
ordinance what we were concerned about
was only the specific section that said
30 feet is the way that you define what
is unreasonable the town disagreed with
that we thought we were actually opening
up opportunities for everybody treating
everybody the same and allowing not only
the performers and the businesses but
also the visitors to enjoy everything
that was being heard out on a boardwalk
in the end a judge granted a preliminary
injunction stopping the 30-foot
restriction leaving City Hall to rewrite
its ban we're going to go back and take
a look at it we're going to see what it
is we can do that would be acceptable
and reasonable for everybody the same
hopes this will send a message to other
cities considering similar noise
ordinances if I were not prevailed you
would have
other communities elsewhere passing laws
that say spoken words can't be audible
for more than 50 feet musical
instruments can't be audible for more
than 30 feet that would go on to books
everywhere so I hope I don't lose
because if I do lose the meaning of a
transcends far beyond violin playing on
a boardwalk
you